hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo los saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
cansados de permanecer bloqueados un
grupo de más de 7000 personas salió en
caravana desde tapachula en el sur de
méxico rumbo a eeuu durante los primeros
días de junio la movilización una de las
más numerosas avanzó por chiapas ante la
mirada de los agentes de migración pero
un acuerdo que les ofrece permisos de
tránsito por al menos 30 días detuvo su
marcha en grupo el acuerdo supone una
luz de esperanza para los que buscan
cruzar la frontera norte mexicana y
ahora más y más personas llegan a la
región a la espera del mismo pase de
movilidad nuestros enviados especiales
andrés suárez jaramillo y aurora bayou
nos traen la historia
la lluvia no cesa en la oficina de
aduanas de huixtla y los migrantes están
hacinados protegiéndose del agua
mientras esperan un documento que les
permita una permanencia legal en mexico
nos encontramos en huixtla a 50
kilómetros de tapachula la ciudad donde
miles de migrantes de la caravana
lograron obtener la forma múltiple de
migración para seguir transitando por
mexico legalmente una suerte que se
desdibuja para los otros cientos de
migrantes que llegan rezagados pero que
no pierden la esperanza de beneficiarse
de la estela de la caravana y poder en
esta ciudad legalizar su estatus
migratorio
laguna mar sin lluvia de por medio este
grupo de aproximadamente 1500 migrantes
se organiza de manera autónoma en un
listado con la ilusión de recibir el
pase migratorio
lo que queremos con la lista de 1º orden
qué es lo que estamos logrando con esto
segundo tener un censo de cuántas
personas no logramos llegar con la
marcha por diferentes razones porque los
niños venían enfermo porque veníamos
mujeres solas porque muchos estuvieron
presos se los llevaron en la misma
marcha los venezolanos por ser mayoría
son los líderes en la organización de
las listas ellos apuntan los nombres de
cubanos colombianos centroamericanos y
africanos pese a que las autoridades ya
les dijeron que para ninguno habrá pase
migratoria
pero nosotros estamos emigrando por la
diferente problemática que se nos
presenta en nuestro país verán entonces
que nosotros lo que queremos es que el
gobierno nos dé respuesta al
inconveniente que se nos está
presentando cuál es el inconveniente el
paso libre por su país tanto la ley
internacional como la mexicana abogan
que toda persona tiene derecho a
solicitar la condición de refugiado pero
en méjico ese trámite se ha convertido
en un tapón burocrático que desgasta día
tras día a miles de solicitantes una
crisis que se agudiza pese a la
declaratoria de 20 países en la reciente
cumbre de las américas para proteger a
los migrantes
y el bloqueo a los eventuales
solicitantes de refugio no sólo se da en
la frontera sur mexicana aunque llegar
al norte es toda una travesía hacerlo no
les garantiza cruzar a estados unidos'
varió álvaro gonzález es un periodista
guatemalteco que tuvo que huir de su
país por amenazas y ahora busca
protección pero aunque lleva meses
esperando todavía no tiene una respuesta
positiva alva santana nos cuenta su
historia
nunca lo imagino pero el periodista
guatemalteco mario álvaro gonzález es
ahora migrante parado en ciudad juárez
méxico después de que su vida diera un
vuelco tras recibir amenazas en su país
natal que yo cantaba detrás de los
políticos pero le dije mira yo atrás
porque ese es mi trabajo el eje 1 era no
es un tema de que yo sea personal y pues
no importa y se produce a cargo sino
desaparecer estamos desaparecer menos en
el mundo del periodismo desde hace más
de 15 años ha colaborado con medios como
routers o tienen trabajando en varios
documentales sobre migración desde
centroamérica pues hoy me veo yo
adelante la cámara no atrae y yo en
guatemala hice muchas historias de
inmigración y hoy me toca a mí que
contar la mía muy lejos de guatemala
verdad y comparte la esperanza de muchos
que le acepten la petición de asilo en
eeuu
cuando vine yo aquí a jugar es en el mes
de octubre el 28 de octubre
nos entregamos la migración después van
a ayudar soy periodista no fue así y me
sacaron dijeron de que no podíamos
entrar por título 42 mi esposa llorando
porque teníamos la esperanza de poder
pasar cuando llegó a méxico con tal et y
su familia sufrieron abusos por parte de
un coyote una realidad que muchos
migrantes han vivido llegando incluso a
ser asesinados por estos traficantes de
personas y las mafias en su intento por
llegar a estados unidos
por la lucha los numerosos peligros de
la travesía estancia y los bloqueos en
su avanzada no los detienen datos
recientes revelados por el gobierno
mexicano revelan un incremento
interanual del 89 por ciento en el
número de emigrantes que se presentaron
ante las autoridades migratorias es
decir más de 77.000 entre enero y marzo
de este año
y el dato de migración de la semana con
una serie animada de cuatro episodios la
agencia de la onu para los refugiados
explica de forma fácil y didáctica
cuestiones importantes sobre el derecho
a solicitar asilo en la frontera
méxico-eeuu y responde a preguntas como
qué es el asilo y quién lo solicita el
embajador de buena voluntad de acnur el
actor ben stiller narra parte de estas
historias que se pueden ver en la página
web de la agencia
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]